je vous le disais un peu plus tôt dans
ce contexte plus d'un million
d'ukrainiens ont fui le pays selon l'onu
ils se réfugient notamment vers les pays
voisins la hongrie la roumanie la
moldavie et surtout en première ligne la
pologne ont rejoint comme promis notre
envoyé spécial tarek écailles vous êtes
hms c'est une ville de 60000 habitants
vieux à peu près tout près de la
frontière ukrainienne et c'est donc là
qu'arrive beaucoup de réfugiés comment
se passe leur prise en charge darek
bien réfugiés continuent à affluer dans
cette ville de chômage comme vous l'avez
dit ville le frontalière de l'ukraine
première à grandes villes européennes ce
mouvement est incessant nous trouvons
actuellement en périphérie de la ville
où un centre commercial désaffecté a été
dédiée à l'accueil au transfert de ces
réfugiés vers des villes polonaises ou
encore d'autres villes européennes c'est
un élan extraordinaire de solidarité qui
a lieu ici l'activité que vous voyez
d'un à moi est incessante nuitées jour
des volontaires se relaient pour
apporter de l'aide il faut savoir que
l'essentiel de cette activité de cette
aide humanitaire repose sur les
volontaires et sur les organisations
humanitaires ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que de manière quotidienne arrive ici
près de dix mille réfugiés venant de
l'autre côté de la frontière dans une
ville qui compte soixante mille
habitants donc dix mille réfugiés à peu
près qui arrive c'est un chiffre énorme
et le but ici c'est d'accueillir plus
vite ces gens de leur donner à boire à
manger des vêtements chauds des jouets
pour les enfants ou même des cartes sim
et ensuite de faciliter leur transfert
de fluidifier le transfert de ces
personnes afin d'en accueillir d'autres
des volontaires donc ce relais comme je
les dis on en a parlé à beaucoup qui se
disent déjà très fatigués certains n'ont
presque pas dormi depuis des jours mais
ils disent que l'effort des efforts
doivent continuer afin d'apporter l'aide
nécessaire ya également des gestes
spontanés de la part d'autres citoyens
européens il ya des voitures par exemple
immatriculé en allemagne de simples
citoyens qui viennent ici pour proposer
de la place pour transférer
ces citoyens ukrainiens qui fit la
guerre pour aller de l'autre côté dans
d'autres pays en allemagne ou dans
d'autres pays dans l'oubli merci